go ahead let's do it let's just start
with 20 years and 40 seasons like when
you signed on as a host of Survivor did
you think for a minute you'd be doing it
20 years later there I mean 40 seasons
is amazing thing
there's no way 20 years ago any of us
when we're walking through the muddy
jungle in the South China Sea would ever
dream we'd still be doing it 20 years
later and what did you think that first
time you stepped onto the set you signed
on to do the job and then there you were
in the jungle with these people where
where was your mind at for that first
season for those first couple of shows I
remember vividly where my mind was
because it wasn't like a normal TV show
yet Mark Burnett he was like the Pied
Piper we're literally were in the jungle
every day as he's kind of figuring it
out you know what is this show really
about it's about epic journeys and
heroes and villains and I just had this
unbridled enthusiasm and I thought it
would be the greatest summer of my life
and then I would do something else but I
was going to enjoy those 39 days here's
the kicker to that I've enjoyed every
single season I still have that same
enthusiasm today that I had 20 years ago
that's incredible and it's funny I was
talking to rob Boston Rob and amber and
they still have the same enthusiasm
about being on the show you know they
has wonderful relationship but they I
sat across from them and I could feel
their hunger to get on the show have to
have Jeff the host there be in those
those raised steak events right where
they felt all those things it's really
amazing you guys all share them there's
something about Survivor and I think
it's why so many kids dig the show is it
does speak to a part of our spirit sure
it has a million-dollar prize and it's
on television but when you are dropped
in a jungle and said you figure it out
you you have to make fire or make
shelter or fight you know fine catch
fish whatever there is something about
that that's in all of us right and I
meet families all the time I mean every
day where they go we've never missed an
episode and the kids say the same thing
which is I'm gonna be on one day
and it's happening now we've been on so
long that I meet people all the time in
casting in the go you know I started
watching when I was five and I can't
believe I'm gonna be on them and that's
that's another thing this show has
resonated with so many generations yeah
people from the first season to now
obviously being over to you know 20
years two decades but still you have the
youngest ones that you could imagine
watching it you have the older
generation they're loving it everybody's
in so invested in it what what else is
it that grabs these people is it the
competition is that the you know seeing
people broken down and to kind of this
raw honest form what what is it exactly
you should be the spokesperson for
survive can you tell like I'm like an
instant fan like just from from the
first time and then I just got caught
this 40 year you know or the 40 season
where they had all these great moments
and right we forget it's almost like
what Tom Hanks is two movies
survivor is to the reality rich brother
it is so much a part of our lives yeah
that we forget all these events and you
lived with these characters over the
time but what is it what what else what
can you put it in the words that grabs
the viewers well you just made me think
when you talked about generations the
very first season of Survivor had a gay
man Richard Hatch partnered up with a 72
year old 45 year Navy SEAL veteran Rudy
they became best friends
it had a truck driver and Sue and a
doctor this doctor Sean they became
allies and it was this idea of if we
truly take all the different types of
people from different walks of life and
we made you coexist could you and the
answer was yes and then on top of it we
said but here's the twist you have to
vote people out every few days you got
to get rid of somebody now who do you
get rid of the strong the weak and over
the 20 years I think that's why
generationally it still resonates is
that if you're 70 you can imagine
all right I'm 70 how would I do out
there and if you're 17 or if you're
seven or if you're 47 you have the same
entry point but all of it comes down to
the same thing do you have it in you
survivors not a shiny stage show it's
not a trivia where you answer a question
this is
you we're gonna dump you there's no
cheat there's no secrets there's no
hidden door there's no bathroom there's
no candy bar
it really has such great humanity about
it dang like you said bringing these
different people together but without
ever losing its competitive edge right
all were pure creatures of opportunity
right we everybody wants to win they
want to look for that opportune moment
to get that one one little step above
but they have to remain honest to their
humanity through the whole thing which
is you just hit the core of it there are
three words on the survivor logo outwit
outplay outlast and what it's saying is
there are no rules
only your's so as you mentioned humanity
where's my line in the sand is it okay
to lie about the kids that I don't even
have if I'm okay with it then it's okay
that's why it's so fun to watch is you
do get permission to manipulate persuade
cajole lie whatever it takes to get you
where I want you and I when I talk to
families they talk about the lessons
they give kids which is sometimes you
have to persuade how would you persuade
that guy to do what you want right now
where's your line it's fun if I can see
it in your eyes like you're infecting me
with your love for the show it's a
beauty it's what I do it's awesome in a
season of all winners and earning a
million dollars in the process is not
enough to inspire you how about two
million dollars
and now we are in season 40 how and why
is this season unique to you other than
the fact that you're dealing with the
pro-bowl of Survivor
contestants they're all winners how is
it unique to you and and how are you
guys keeping these pros guessing yeah
it's a great question yeah the one thing
you don't want to do in your 40th season
is just sit back and celebrate well you
have to continue to plow ahead and so
from a game standpoint we're bringing in
money currency and the idea is that any
society at some point introduces money
this thing that we agree has a value and
now we're gonna use it and that's the
the thing that levels the playing field
this season is you now have 20 winners
but there's a new twist how is money
going to change survivor and it's going
to usher in a new era 40 is not the end
40 is the beginning of something new and
we're using winners to teach us how to
play this new version of Survivor right
I know it's bad to brag about your own
show it's not this season is so good
kids are gonna lose their mind on it it
really is it's so fun to watch now over
the years of as strange as it may sound
there's been so much so many show manses
on the show right and so what is it
about the competitive circumstance that
lends itself to relationships sparks so
often what do you have an answer it's a
great question no one's ever asked it
that way and I think it is what you just
said is when you're heightened when your
emotions are heightened or when you're
physically challenged in your there's
adrenaline and there's this acceleration
of things that are happening you want to
share it with somebody but on Survivor
there's nobody to trust so on the rare
occasions where two people actually
realized we actually have chemistry in
this weird jungle world I think it's
really heightened and we had a couple
Boston Rob and amber who met and let us
watch them fall in love they let us
watch them kiss for the first time then
they got engaged on the show then they
got married on CBS now they have four
kids and they're back to play again
it's pretty cool if you had to pick your
favorite most iconic three moments of
the length of the show Wow I know it's
tough because I feel like for you the
way you clearly feel so passionate about
it every show every experiences this
great iconic moment but if three that do
it out to you I got three the very first
minutes of the first day of the first
season I'll never forget it because it
was a live event we rehearsed what we
thought was going to happen but then we
all got together we said okay we have 16
people we don't know what they're going
to do we're gonna get on this boat we're
gonna tell them to jump off and then
we're gonna start following if somebody
starts to drown we've got a safety
swimmer somewhere right we don't okay it
was that kind of a feeling that's when I
wasn't the most and then in the all-star
season in 2004 Rob proposed to Amber
live at Madison Square Garden and I was
standing there as he was doing it
watching the audience cheering wanting
them to be in love and it that was the
first time I understood they the
audience are invested in the players
they're rooting either for them or
against them but in this case it was we
watched you fall in love ask her to
marry say yes to him and then the third
time was the opening minutes of this
season because it was it hit me weirdly
in an emotional way when these 20 people
walk up on the Sandspit and what I saw
was my own twenty years of life
I remember amber being a young woman in
the year 2000 in Australia and now she's
a mother with four kids and I remember
all of these different people and so I
saw my own life sort of oh I was single
here I started to mature there I met my
amazing wife there and now we have a kid
it is for me the same thing now I know
we have basically talked about this but
over the 40 seasons how has the show
most changed you
it what is it responsible for in your
life other than this wonderful career
that you love what you do but how is it
most shaped you your your experiences
with these different people and this
show with almost being a heartbeat of
its own I think the biggest change in me
is that in the first season I thought I
was the center of the universe so every
story revolved around my filters and and
what survivors shown me is that
everybody should feel that way that they
are the center of their own universe
that but that we are all a grain of sand
together and that sounds may be a little
corny but it's watching all of these
other stories and realizing man their
life is completely different than mine
but just as important to them as mine is
to me and I found much more compassion
I'm a better listener I can sit and
listen to somebody at Tribal Council
talk in a way that I know will never
make the show but I know you need to say
it and I'm you're trying to tell me
something and I'm listening and maybe
it'll turn our story somewhere or maybe
it won't but I think that patience and
hopefully some self-awareness that I'm
still learning is the biggest lesson
talk to us about that how the Tribal
Council itself you said you can sit
there and really listen to this very
event you know they need it how long
does it go or how short does it go
sometimes that's the great question is
sometimes they go very long and
sometimes by design we keep them very
short and it really depends on where we
are in the story sometimes I'll show up
and I can tell there's just a lot to
talk about there's a lot of people
they've got things on their mind it's
clear that they're not sure what they're
doing yet who they're gonna vote out
they probably have a plan but they also
have a plan B and a Plan C but this
person clearly has a plan F that they're
trying to get to write other tribals so
tribals can range anywhere from an hour
and a half like if it was really intense
and nobody wanted to vote yet because
they weren't sure what they wanted to do
we'll go all night and I remind them
every time it's your tribal I'll sit
here all night I got nowhere else
nothing else to do sometimes you walk in
and you can feel a different uncertainty
and so all I'll make tribal really
short and force the game say okay
question question question shall we vote
and people like huh shall we vote yeah
yeah yeah okay let's vote an interesting
so the point is to keep them on their
toes but to also give them plenty of
room when they want it and I think it's
hard for them sometimes to remember I'm
not in charge
I'm just the idiot asking the questions
it's your game there are no rules other
than you have to vote one of you out
tonight but for any reason and we'll be
here as long as you want
you've praised so many things about the
human behavior of the show that that
results in a positive thing what is it
that bugs you about some people and
their decisions when they're put in
these circumstance well you know one of
the things that people complain about a
lot is they say these people know
they're going in a jungle right why
don't they learn how to make fire I have
no idea I have the same question like
how did all you have to do is go to
Amazon order a flint and practice in
your backyard people show up in the guy
I don't what is the Flint how does it
work I don't know but what frustrates me
the most is when people start to lie
down and die and you see them curl up in
a ball and I will often say I just want
to make sure I have this right cuz it's
clear to me
you're going home and you're letting it
happen you left your family you left
your job you came out here you you have
bug bites everywhere and you're giving
up man really did we put the wrong
person on this show because we don't
want people who want to give up and it's
amazing how many times people will sit
forward and go hang on I'm not done I
want to talk some more and that's the
moment that I'm looking for cuz dude
that's why we're out here to see what
you're capable of so pick it up stop
complaining let's go play the game we
have had so many moments on Survivor
where somebody was in a situation that
they just wanted to quit
we had one I'm thinking of right now
this woman Surrey in the middle of the
ocean in the middle of a challenge and
she couldn't pull herself up onto this
platform she just physically yeah she
couldn't do it the challenge ended her
tribe lost and I said we're not going
anywhere until you tell us to cuz what
why else are we here but for you to see
what you're capable of and man she just
kept digging and digging him finally she
pulls herself up and then
she crosses the balance beam and in her
interview she says I did that for my
kids because I didn't want them to see
mom quit and I wasn't sure I could get
up on that platform and you're
vulnerable
there is no help it's the ocean it the
waves are moving but those moments move
me so much because even though you lost
the takeaway was this giant victory yeah
huge life-changing life-changing yeah
[Music]